well today is ash wednesday the
beginning of lent for millions of
catholics around the world behind me
we're looking live right now at vatican
city in rome headquarters for the
catholic church here in the valley
attending mass on ash wednesday is
returning to a more normal celebration
hector mejia joins us live this morning
to explain how churches are recovering
from the pandemic good morning hector
good morning sheri and here at guardian
angel cathedral they tell me they've
been seeing larger crowds thankfully in
recent weeks and we've learned the
pandemic is having less of an impact on
ash wednesday this year churches all
across the valley have adapted from
having to close altogether to only being
able to host small crowds now they don't
have to have the mask mandate in place
the ash wednesday more than a thousand
years old affected by the pandemic
father bob stokie at guardian angel
cathedral says this will be the first
time they'll be able to put a cross on
the forehead with larger crowds since
the pandemic began
last year we were advised to sprinkle
ashes on the head which is still a
tradition in parts of europe but has not
been so much the american tradition
because we were still
while not only wearing masks but then
also uncertain as
we were learning more and more about
kobe
service for ash wednesday will also hold
a prayer for
people caught in the war in ukraine
father bob stoking expects people to
light candles throughout the day here
and this is just one of several churches
all across the valley moving forward
with the ash wednesday tradition
the service here begins at nine o'clock
this morning reporting live hector mejia
live local now